did you know that quentin tarantino has
considered making a sequel to reservoir
dogs 30 years in the making
when did he write a number one new york
times bestseller and did a cameo as
elvis on the golden girls really fund
his first movie do you know everything
about quentin tarantino or are you a
square find out right here
though quentin tarantino might sound
like a stage name his birth name was
indeed quentin jerome tarantino his
mother named him after a bert reynolds
character quint asper from gunsmoke he
inherited his last name from his dad
tony tarantino but grew up using the
last name zostapil after his stepfather
in a 2021 appearance on the wtf podcast
with mark maron tarantino admitted that
if he were starting his career today
he'd probably use his middle name making
once upon a time in hollywood a film
from visionary director quentin jerome
tarantino explained to mark maron
i didn't even know about the name
tarantino really at that time zostapil
was my name i was always known by that
although his mother had remarried
musician curtis zastapill when quentin
got into his late teens he began to feel
like his biological father's name just
sounded better it sounded cool it was
italian yeah yeah tarantino sounded like
a cool name it had nothing to do with
him it had nothing to do with the family
quentin tarantino was born in knoxville
tennessee but he mostly grew up in
california his mother met his father
when she came to los angeles in the
early 60s on a trip she was briefly
married to the law student and aspiring
entertainer but after their divorce
moved back to knoxville to be with her
parents
tarantino and his mom both returned to
la however when he was about 3 years old
in a 2010 interview with the uk
telegraph tarantino had this to say
about his birth father i never knew my
father he wanted to be an actor now he's
an actor only because of my last name
but he was never part of my life i
didn't know him i've never met him born
in queens and raised in brooklyn tony
tarantino became an actor because of his
father dominic who appeared in westerns
in the 1930s
according to imdb tony has acted in 10
projects and produced two films quentin
and tony's estrangement has occasionally
made headlines as in 2015 when the two
publicly disagreed over matters of
police brutality
tarantino has also had a difficult
relationship with his mother at times in
a 2021 interview with the moment podcast
the director said he's been hesitant to
assist his mom financially because of
memories from when he was young and
trying to write early scripts i spend a
lot of time writing my scripts
and then when i'm done
now i gotta go make the movie
some of these early scripts would
eventually go on to form the basis of
films like reservoir dogs true romance
and natural born killers the problem it
seems is that he was working on these
scripts during school time tarantino
said on the podcast
in the middle of her little tirade she
said oh and by the way this little
writing career with the finger quotes
this little writing career that you're
doing that is over she just meant don't
do it in class when you're supposed to
be doing something else all these
decades later tarantino still remembers
the exchange recalling when she said
that to me in that sarcastic way i was
in my head and i go okay lady when i
become a successful writer you will
never see one penny from my success
there will be no house for you there's
no vacation for you you get nothing
because you said that ultimately he said
he has stuck to that resolution
revealing i helped her out of a jam with
the irs but no house no cadillac
anybody who knows anything about quentin
tarantino knows the backstory in the 80s
he was among the resident geeks at the
now legendary video archive store in
manhattan beach aside from writing my
scripts that no one ever read
you know my only form of artistic
expression was
managing this video store
in perhaps one of his most famous quotes
tarantino told the bbc in 2004 when
people ask me if i went to film school i
tell them no i went to films it was at
video archives where tarantino would
hold court behind the counter and watch
so many of those films tarantino told
nbc news in 2004 i was just looking for
a minimum wage job
i could have worked at video archives i
could have worked at pioneer chicken but
luckily i got in at video archives and
it was real fun
tarantino had spent much of his life
going to movies and by the time he was
applying at video archives he was
already a walking encyclopedia of film
history the director told nbc news i got
the job because i was a movie expert
when you clear out everything in your
life and focus on one thing you better
know a lot about it until i became a
director it was the best job i'd ever
had
as streaming services have increasingly
influenced the film industry directors
like christopher nolan and steven
spielberg have made their opinions known
on the perceived threat to cinema nobody
loves film more than tarantino
and since he's never been known for
being shy the reservoir dog's director
has made his opinion on the matter known
commenting on the rise of streaming
services tarantino had this to say in a
2015 indie wire interview i am not
excited about streaming at all i like
something hard and tangible in my hand
and i can't watch a movie on a laptop i
don't use netflix at all i don't have
any sort of delivery system in a 2017
interview with the playlist tarantino
talked about how going to a video store
was more of an investment and a more
communal experience admitting there was
a different quality to the video store
you looked around you picked up boxes
you read the back of the boxes you made
a choice and maybe you talked to the guy
behind the counter and maybe he pointed
you towards something these days video
stores are largely gone and tarantino's
movies have made their way to streaming
services perhaps he has even warmed to
the possibilities of streaming in 2019
tarantino worked with netflix on a much
hyped longer cut of the hateful eight
keep in mind this was shortly after he
had toured the movie on 70 millimeter
film pretty much as old school as you
can get and perhaps proof that celluloid
and streaming can indeed co-exist
tarantino told slash film netflix came
to us and said hey look if you'd be
interested in putting it together and in
a way that we could show it as three or
four episodes we'd be willing to do that
i thought wow that's really intriguing i
was game to give that a shot
though tarantino says he's been to jail
there have been questions surrounding
these claims over the years and even
accusations that such stories are an
attempt to make himself seem like a
tough guy tarantino told the movie
themed tv what the flick in 2015. i was
in jail three different times the last
time was for eight days three days one
time two days another time and then
eight days the last time
the new york post published an article
labeling his story a lie claiming
there's no record of his time served at
a los angeles county jail tarantino
fired back saying they're just really
bad journalists it would be so easy for
them to look it up but they're actually
not doing the work that it takes to look
it up
tarantino is also fond of telling a
story about childhood shoplifting that
has since gone on to become part of his
legend when he was 15 he stole a copy of
the elmore leonard crime paperback the
switch from a kmart in torrance
california
after being arrested and released by the
police he was grounded for the summer by
his mother once he had served his time
he went back and stole the book this
time successfully tarantino claims he
still has the book and about 20 years
later it's leonard penned quasi sequel
rum punch would help serve as source
material for one of his most beloved
films jackie brown
love him or hate him there's no debate
tarantino's movies are often violent
unrelenting depictions of murder mayhem
and dismemberment from the cop's ear and
reservoir dogs to the bride's blood
spraying kill bill showdown with the
crazy 88 the man is responsible for more
severed body parts than your average
neighborhood carnival ride in real life
he has been asked about violence for
decades and has at times become angered
by the constant implications that it is
hypocritical to put such violence in his
movies for fun yet condemn it in the
real world well i just reject your
hypothesis
tarantino told the observer in 1994 to
say that i get a big kick out of
violence in movies and can enjoy
violence in movies but find it totally
important in real life i can feel
totally justified and totally
comfortable with that statement real
life violence is real life violence
movies or movies while doing publicity
in 2013 for django unchained arguably
his most violent film tarantino went
viral with a confrontational interview
with a british journalist the director
shot back when the uk channel 4
interview tried to press him on the
issue of violence in his movies and i'm
shutting your butt down
explaining repeatedly that he'd already
answered questions about that topic
multiple times in the past tarantino
went on to add i refuse your question
i'm not your slave and you're not my
master you can't make me dance to your
tune i'm not a monkey
tarantino has been involved in many
classic films and not just the ones he's
directed but also some he has had a hand
in writing or acting in although an
exact timeline is hard to nail down true
romance was the first script for a major
motion picture he sold natural born
killers was a movie he wrote for himself
but didn't yet have the clout to direct
and from dusk till dawn was his first
paid writing gig
in a 2009 interview with backwoods
horror.com special effects legend robert
kurtzman who is credited for coming up
with the story of from dusk till dawn
remembered how tarantino came onto the
project saying i conceived the project
and wrote a treatment that outlined the
film and the characters producer david
goodman had told me about a young writer
who he thought would be perfect to write
dusk
he hooked us up and cute tea and i soon
got together to discuss collaborating
kurtzman said that he and his producers
didn't have a lot of money to pay
tarantino but it was enough cash for the
then aspiring filmmaker to leave his job
to write the script for from dusk till
dawn full-time
kurtzman told the website it was
actually tarantino's first work for hire
screenplay we made a deal qt would write
our script and i would do the special
effects for reservoir we spent the next
10 years trying to set the film up it
was initially rejected everywhere even
after the success of reservoir and pulp
by the mid-90s however the heat had
become too hot around tarantino and el
mariachi filmmaker robert rodriguez to
ignore so dusk finally got the green
light the film starred harvey keitel
juliet lewis selma hayek and some guy
named george clooney who was trying to
make the jump from television to movies
now do we all agree that what we are
dealing with is vampires
tarantino would turn in arguably the
most substantial acting performance he's
ever given as the lewd brother to
clooney's character kurtzman added when
rodriguez became interested it was a
no-brainer once rodriguez boarded the
pitcher it went from what was conceived
as a small 1.5 million dollar movie to a
17 million dollar film with top name
talent the rest is history reportedly
tarantino received a mere 1500 to write
the script
tarantino's oscar juggernaut once upon a
time in hollywood made just under 400
million dollars worldwide at the box
office making it the second highest
grossing film of his career but it ranks
alone in his filmography when it comes
to book sales the novelization of once
upon a time in hollywood marked the
writer director's debut as an author
arriving at number one on the new york
times fiction bestseller list if you've
seen the film you know that it exists in
an extremely detailed alternate reality
where fictional characters live mingle
and co-star with very real legends like
bruce lee tarantino used his
novelization to not only recount the
story in prose but to dive even deeper
into his character's backstories readers
learned for instance that rick killed
more japanese soldiers in world war ii
than anyone in u.s military history and
that cliff did indeed kill his wife
speaking about the book on an episode of
the pure cinema podcast tarantino had
this to say i'm really happy with it i'm
really proud of it if you're a fan of
the movie i think you will get a kick
out of reading the book and exploring
the characters further it's not just me
taking the screenplay and then breaking
it down in a novelistic form i retold
the story as a novel
if you're a fan of tarantino's writing
you'll be happy to learn that a new book
involving dicaprio's character dalton is
also on the way although the 1992 crime
classic reservoir dogs is technically
tarantino's first feature-length film it
was not his first attempt at getting a
filmmaking career off the ground in 1983
he collaborated with friend scott mcgill
on love birds in bondage a film he
intended to star in co-write and
co-direct whatever footage was shot of
that film was eventually destroyed a few
years later tarantino got closer with my
best friend's birthday that film told
the story of a man named mickey whose
girlfriend recently left him tarantino
played clarence who was trying to make
his friend feel better via a surprise
years later tarantino would call the
comedy a martin and lewis kind of thing
and shot the film while working at video
archives alongside roger avery who
served as a cinematographer seven years
later these indie film geeks would be
standing on stage at the oscars sharing
a best original screenplay trophy for
pulp fiction by the time pulp fiction
comes out i'm actually a no at least
among the critics i'm a known entity
history apparently repeated itself and
the legend goes that much of friend's
birthday was lost in a fire although
tarantino has since said that the fire
story isn't true either way only 36
minutes of the film remain and it is in
a barely watchable black and white and
fuzzy format but if you're curious you
can view the footage online with dark
rants about how the partridge family
saved his character from suicide you can
see the early seeds of tarantino's
genius
writers actors directors producers and
everyone in between are expected to
flesh out hit after hit tarantino as an
example is expected to make a movie
that's not only met with critical
acclaim but one that also reaches glory
at the box office achieving all these
feats takes a myriad of things to go
right all starting with a well-written
script i was bam i was seen as a writer
director from the very beginning
as for the 2009 war film in glorious
bastards tarantino worked on it for
nearly a decade tarantino wrote kill
bill volume 1 in between writing and
glorious bastards and at one point was
considering names like adam sandler and
michael madsen for roles the extra time
he took with this script paid off as
bastards was nominated for eight oscars
racked up over 300 million dollars
worldwide at the box office and brought
tarantino's career roaring back to
prominence although a decade might seem
like a long time to work on a script
tarantino's patience and willingness to
get it right paid off in spades that's a
bingo
[Music]
is that the way you say it that's a
bingo
you just say bingo
in 1988 a young tarantino still
struggling to gain traction in hollywood
as a writer director or actor appeared
on an episode of the hit sitcom the
golden girls
he was one of many elvis impersonators
in sofia's wedding part 1 and believe it
or not dorothy rose sophia and blanche
helped finance reservoir dogs albeit in
an extremely indirect way in a 2020
appearance on the tonight show starring
jimmy fallon tarantino revealed that he
made about three thousand dollars in
residuals from his appearance on the
two-part episode the director added and
that kept me going during our post for a
pre-production time trying to get
reservoir dogs going so thank golden
girls for reservoir dogs
as any tarantino die hard knows he is an
elvis admirer in true romance christian
slater's character clarence gets regular
visits from a jiminy cricket like elvis
played by val kilmer additionally pulp
fiction has a deleted scene where mia
wallace explains that the world is
filled with two types of people elvis
people and beatles people now beatles
people can like elvis and elvis people
can like beetles but nobody likes them
both equally
in a 2019 interview with uncut tarantino
reiterated his love for the king telling
the outlet when i was young i used to
think elvis was the voice of truth i
don't know what that means but his voice
man it sounded so pure the hillbilly cat
never let you down
tarantino might be viewed as a filmmaker
above all else but he actually has more
acting credits than directing ones as of
may 2022 tarantino has 21 director
credits to his name yet his 38 acting
credits surpass that he also has 22
producer credits and 30 writing credits
as well as a whopping 252 self credits
tarantino by all measures has left his
mark on hollywood from behind and in
front of the camera if you're looking
for some off the beaten path tarantino
acting you can look beyond the obvious
cameos and reservoir dogs pulp fiction
and django unchained and take a peek at
the fun episode of all american girl he
did in 1995 spoofing pulp fiction
alongside then-girlfriend margaret cho
a couple years later he would appear in
spike lee's girl 6 as a thinly veiled
version of himself and his off-the-wall
appearance as a blind preacher in adam
sandler's little nicky has to be seen to
be believed
it's rare to find creators who don't
like their own characters but there are
certainly exceptions especially when
those characters are just plain horrible
to say tarantino doesn't fancy the
calvin candy character played by
leonardo dicaprio in django unchained is
an understatement
in a 2012 interview with playboy
magazine the director had this to say
about his cinematic creation
i hated candy and i normally like my
villains no matter how bad they are i
could see his point of view but i hated
it so much for the first time as a
writer i just hated this guy going along
with that sentiment dicaprio also
appears to find the character despicable
the oscar-winning actor told ew in 2012
he was one of the most deplorable
indulgent horrendous characters i've
ever read in my life this man's code of
ethics was so beyond or below anything
that i could ever imagine but it was a
delicious character nonetheless
product placement is an unfortunate
necessity in almost any modern movie but
from the very beginnings of his career
tarantino has sidestepped brand names
whenever possible to instead use hyper
real tarantino universe brands such as
the hawaiian fast food restaurant big
kahuna burger and red apple cigarettes
let me pack the red apples
fans could reasonably expect that
tarantino must hate product placement
but the opposite is apparently true
according to the alter it's the real
life brands who typically don't want to
be featured in his films while being
interviewed in the 2011 film the
greatest movie ever sold tarantino said
i haven't done that much product
placement in my movies because for the
most part i've actually been usually
refused all of my first scripts had some
scenes that took place at a denny's in
both cases denny's goes no
when you have a long-standing career
like quentin tarantino and such a
distinctive brand hollywood will come
knocking regularly coupled with
tarantino's methods of beginning
projects then moving elsewhere if he
loses interest there is a long list of
whatakuda movies that qt's fans will
most likely never see tarantino films
that never came to fruition include
double v vega perhaps the most
tantalizing unproduced project which
would have brought together the
similarly surnamed characters of vic
vega played by michael madsen in
reservoir dogs and vincent vega played
by john travolta in pulp fiction
even though both died in their
respective movies tarantino told the
real blend podcast in 2019
it would have taken place in amsterdam
so it would have taken place in the time
that vincent was in amsterdam at some
point vic shows up to visit him and it
would have been their weekend exactly
what happens to them or what trouble
they get into i never took it that far
depending on who you believe tarantino
has also either pitched or been pitched
attempts to mix his unique flavor with
star trek james bond russ meyer and even
the marvel superhero luke cage long
before the mcu was a thing as for his
own films a persistent rumor continues
that he could do a third chapter of kill
bill in a 2021 appearance on the joe
rogan experience podcast tarantino
explained that the story would have the
daughter of vivica a fox's character out
for vengeance the movie would also
reportedly cast uma thurman's real-life
daughter maya hawk as the offspring of
beatrix kiddo the director went on to
add i think it's just revisiting the
characters 20 years later and just
imagining the bride and her daughter
bibi having 20 years of peace and then
that peace is shattered and now the
bride and bibi are on the run tarantino
has even thought about revisiting one of
his own classics
in a 2021 appearance on real time with
bill maher the director told the host i
actually considered about doing a remake
of reservoir dogs as my last movie i
won't do it internet all right but i i
considered it
if any of those projects are going to
come to fruition tarantino better hurry
up and choose carefully because he has
been going on record for years claiming
that after 10 films he will walk away
this is a position he has reiterated
even after the massive success of once
upon a time in hollywood which would
count as film number nine by his
estimation qt seems determined to go out
on top and is well aware of brilliant
filmmakers whose final efforts
diminished their canon you're at the top
of your game why that's why i want to
quit
asked if he was serious the then 58 year
old filmmaker made his case telling bill
maher i've given it everything i have
every
single solitary thing
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebs are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]